Liebe leute ich muss. Mal wieder dampf ablassen was dann wieder in berlin passiert spottet jeder
beschreibung auf der einen seite muss der bundesverkehrsminister die zulassung von zehntausenden a6 und a7
von audi mit einem dreiliter dieselmotor zurück ziehen wegen unzulässiger abschalt software
Also betrug eine absolut peinliche geschichte jetzt immer noch aber
noch, peinlicher wird es wenn, er auf der anderen seite eine reduktion des co2
Ausstoßes bei pkw und kleinen nutzfahrzeugen, um die hälfte bis achtung nur
2030 ablehnt grund für mich mal dampf abzulassen herzlich willkommen bei gigs und salzen fiction
Da geht mir echt einer ab der mann ist doch offensichtlich ja abgas vergiftet oder sowas andreas scheuer von der csu seines zeichens
Verkehrsminister hat der den schuss nicht gehört der man sagt doch allen ernstes
Wir brauchen keine willkürlichen politisch. Ideologischen grenzwerte nach dem muster pi mal. Daumen sondern
realistische technisch machbare grenzwerte die vernichtung einer
europäischen leitindustrie mache ich nicht mit herzlich willkommen in wolkenkuckucksheim
Der mann hat offensichtlich. Noch nichts von der klimakatastrophe gehört was stimmt denn bei dem nicht die mal. Daumen wir wissen
Noch, mal, wir wissen wir hängen mit der reduzierung von co2 weltweit total hinterher von wegen pi mal
Daumen, und auch die bundesrepublik wird trotz des niedergangs der industrie im osten
ihr selbstgestecktes ziel der reduktion des kohlendioxid ausstoßes, um 40 prozent
Um acht prozentpunkte also tatsächlich 20 prozent verfehlen was für ein fehler und dann sagt der verkehrsminister noch
So, ein blödsinn übersetzt lieber vernichten wir die erde mit jedweder leitindustrie
Und unser gleich mit und noch etwas kommt hinzu. Und das hat die
Bundesumweltministerin svenja schulze von der spd ganz gut formuliert wenn die deutsche autoindustrie mit alten technologien, und betrug software
Ihre existenz sichern muss. Dann sehen, sie, sich den, ast ab auf dem sie sitzt schon jetzt gibt die autoindustrie
Wohl bei der batterieentwicklung auf und will diese kerntechnologie wohl nur einkaufen
Und stattdessen die audi stecken die autohersteller weiterhin, ihre
Kompetenz in die programmierung von betrug software das kann doch nicht sein es ist schlimm für die arbeiter. Und angestellten
Die totengräber sind ihre chefs man darf nicht vergessen dass die. Anstehenden klagen die autokonzerne
Milliarden kosten werden die klagen wegen der preisabsprachen der lkw hersteller sind furchtbar pro lkw wird die entschädigung
Auf rund 8000 euro geschätzt und das sind unmengen fahrzeuge die das betrifft und dazu kommt der diesel skandal der auch
Noch viele leben. Kosten
Zehntausende tote pro jahr weltweit laut einer studie sind es allein in europa
Mehr als 10.000 die auf die betrug software zurück gehen also drohte
Grauenhaft da ist es fast. Ein trost wer nicht mit der zeit geht geht mit der zeit die
entwicklungsabteilung bei den autoherstellern
Die tragen, eine große schuld das jahrelange beharren auf ihrem know-how zu verbrennungsmotoren was aber in zukunft nicht. Mehr gebraucht wird
Und dazu noch die umschichtung der umweltanforderungen durch. Kriminellen
Betrug das ist die schlimme schuld die die ingenieure. Und das management dort auf sich geladen haben an menschenleben
Und arbeitsplätzen nicht von ungefähr landen immer mehr ingenieure, und automanager im gefängnis
Und wenn der wandel kommt sind diejenigen die. Ihn aushalten wollten meistens diejenigen die den höchsten
Preis zahlen, müssen aber es gibt, einen trost im bereich der regenerativen energien gibt es immer. Mehr arbeitsplätze mehr als
300.000 sind es aktuell in deutschland und es werden immer. Mehr was die arbeitsplätze in der autoindustrie. Angeht das ist relativ simpel
Zwei gefahren drohen hier der deutschen automobilindustrie. Und hier wird scheinbar geschlafen
It-technologie das zentrum der fahrzeuge von morgen hier greifen apple, und google und auch
Tesla an und zweitens der antrieb der elektroantrieb oder auch der wasserstoffantrieb wenn
Sie nicht exakt in diesen bereichen aufpassen werden sie den anschluss verlieren
Und wer sich an da an solche petitessen wie dem co2 ausstoß
Aufhält hat einfach überhaupt keinen plan die mobilität wird sich in den nächsten
Jahren, massiv ändern ich habe zum beispiel, eine bahncard 100. Und fahrer ein kleines elektroauto und es gibt noch tausend andere
Mobilitätskonzepte mit dem eigenen auto im stau stehen ist jedenfalls. Kein zukunftsmodell geschweige, denn. Dabei auch. Noch unseren planeten zu zerstören
Lieberherr scheuer. Kleine erinnerung sie, sind bundesverkehrsminister. Und nicht bundes auto minister ja wenn
Ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollte die youtube abo box funktioniert
Ja einfach nicht. Dann endet. Mich bei whatsapp nur dann verpasst er kein video whatsapp über web erfahrt. Ihr von mir. Noch vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks
Um, social media abonnieren das geht hier da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt für, eben hier klicken aber nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es war damit. Dafür auch draufklicken
elektroauto wahnsinn da lasse ich auch mal dampf ab bis dann
bleibt